sponsored by step finance your go to
d5 portfolio manager once bitmex the
og crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys anna welcome back to the leia hill plan
show so i am so excited to do this show today
because unfortunately it is looking pretty red
there's a lot of blood in the streets right now
and we have a great guest to go through all
of this and trying to make some sense of it
and figure out where things are going but
before i do bring him on um i want to say
a huge thank you to bit mex because bitmex are
my brand new sponsor this month and without them
we wouldn't be able to bring you such valuable
content so bitmex are a crypto exchange
and as of may 17th they're actually launching a
brand new spot exchange to easily and instantly
buy and sell your assets so to celebrate
they're giving away one million dollars in
crypto to spot traders over the next few months
so this is actually one of the biggest giveaways
in crypto right now so if you do want to enter
i'm going to leave the link for more information
in the description for you um it's gonna be
really exciting there's a lot of different
assets that you can start trading so definitely
go check them out and a huge thank you to bitmex
all right guys let's get things going joining me
today is the one and only ran nuna the host of
the extremely popular crypto banter youtube show
let's bring ran on hey ran how are you it's pretty
hectic out there right now let's just say i've had
better days i mean if that's uh let's say i've had
better days i mean i don't think it's any big
secret to anyone that luna was my biggest bag
i was absolutely irresponsibly long i did
publicize that um and it went wrong and today i'm
dealing with the consequences i think it's going
to be a fan show it's going to be a very personal
show i think it's going to be great i'm actually
right now tweeting telling people to join us
on my channel amazing amazing so luna luna was
your biggest bag um so that is absolutely insane
you were irresponsibly long um can you give us an
idea of how much you've lost and is this overnight
i'm not gonna talk numbers um because the
problem is if i talk numbers i'm opening
myself up for crazy stupid attacks but
let me just give you the history of my
history with luna so that you understand
where i came from i met dokwan and danny
um oh who define who are the founders of luna
in the hashed incubator in 2017 when i was
the first western journalist with cnbc 2017 or
2018 i was the first western journalist to go
to um to korea and cover the crypto scene there
in this in korea there was a fund called hasht
and hashed had an accelerator inside the
accelerator some of the best companies
came out of there and one of these
companies was this young company called
tara luna and they were working on a on a amazing
stable coin they're working on an algorithmic
stablecoin and when i once i left them i was so
impressed with the guys that i ended up investing
i landed up i ended up investing quite a big
portion a manual like a couple hundred thousand
in the audio in ico and i always held the position
and you know when luna was going was at 26 cents
and 27 cents and 28 cents i kept buying more
and more and more and more and more and then
of course that bag exploded and because luna was
such an amazing ecosystem and we really thought
that it was going to be the next algorithmic the
future of money i mean an algorithmic stable coin
which was something completely new a novel um i
invested very heavily in the ecosystem around it
so it's almost like you know if you believe in the
ethereum chain and you invest in you know compound
and rv and all the things that are being built on
the chain so i invested in indexes and i invested
in the meta versus and i invested in the anchor
protocol and i invested in all of those things um
to the point where you know it was irresponsibly
one of my biggest bags and i actually did a very
public stream where i said like you know i'm
irresponsibly long it's one of my biggest bags
and it's time for me to start exiting and over a
period of time i'm going to start exiting my bag
and i did i mean i did i started exiting
into solana and i started exiting into
avalanche and engineer but i didn't do it fast
enough and the reason why i didn't do it fast
enough was a combination of two things
the first thing is greed when you have a
protocol that you are emotionally attached to
and it's bringing you such incredible returns
you don't want to let it go and i kept
fighting it and moving it into other things
other things knowing that i was doing it but
again too slow and i mean the second mistake
is that i wasn't resolute because if i was
resolute what i should have said is hold on
this is now 70 of your portfolio get the [__]
out make it 30 of your portfolio and cut it today
and i didn't do that because you know you always
think that you have the luxury of time i think in
the bull market we all always thought we had the
luxury of time that you know the bull market's
only going to end when there's a blow off top and
one thing that i've learned having experienced
three very very good and very bad markets in
crypto is the bull market always ends way way
way sooner than you expect and the bear market
always lasts way way way longer than you expect
and that's that's the truth of it and every
time we think it's going to be different
and every time we try and convince ourselves that
this time is going to be different or maybe we
even try to convince ourselves that this time was
going to be the same we were going to have that
blow off top we were going to have that fourth
cycle where we were going to have that blow off
top and then it would be the end of the book and
it wasn't so you know you learn lessons as i said
on my stream today today's been one of the hardest
days of my life uh in fact so hard that i thought
of cancelling on you but after last week losing
my voice i thought if i cancelled you again you'll
never go for dinner with me so then i thought
you know let me let me do this and actually
let me use this opportunity to be authentic and
really share my experience and my learnings uh
being on the other side of the microphone because
usually i'm the one interviewing another one in
and now this time i've got someone who
is as great and as professional as you
on the other side who can maybe get it get
this out there and get people listening to this
so you said that you know you met the guys
you liked the project um you know you were
investing on you on the way up you took a little
bit of profit but because of greed obviously
you you didn't sell as much as as much as
you should have done so the question is
what went wrong you know if you how do people
avoid this next time you know like you met the
guys you trusted them how do people avoid
this moving forward it's very tough because
a couple of things the first thing is we
all drink the kool-aid every single day
like we drink crypto kool-aid every single day
now theoretically someone can come to you and say
to you like you know like let's put the [__]
aside you really want me to put money into a
digital coin that i can't touch and feel that is
completely decentralized you really want me dead
now we've bought the kool-aid and we believe
in it and a lot of these concepts that we
believe in are actually going to work but some
of them are not going to work and what we've
got to acknowledge is that every single one of
these things is an experiment and experiments
when you're trying to do new things
experiments are going to fail
and you know when experiments are going
to fail experiments are going to fail
when they get stress tested by by the hardest and
toughest of external forces and then we're really
gonna know if these experiments played out and
let me give you the example of luna for example
so luna now was it's an algorithmic base table
in other words it's backed by nothing and i
think what they did was they made a fundamental
mistake the fundamental mistake is what made them
heroes the fundamental mistake is they said look
we're going to take this algorithmic animal coin
and in order to avoid this thing called
the death spiral and the death spiral is
when people sell their ust and it depends and then
because it depicts more and more and more people
sell their ust because you don't want to be
part of a sinking ship so because it's not
actually backed by anything people made the call
to tap out and it's like we're tapping others and
let's talk about where it actually went wrong
so dokwan who is a very very very smart guy one
of the smartest guys i've ever met also one of
the nicest guys i've ever met that like i might
say that even after all of this and all the money
that i've lost and he's been you could say quite
arrogant and he's displayed hubris and and all the
traits that we don't like we can talk about that
later on in the show he made some massive mistakes
the first mistake is i think he got caught up in
the hype and i think he loved being the king of
the community and you know like when the bitcoin
holders embraced him and like wow he bought
bitcoin and oh there's a new bitcoin bar in town
he it got him and he made a mistake the mistake
was that he started to announce his purchases
now have you ever heard in wall street people
announce their purchases no absolutely not
you don't say i'm going to buy tesla because
the rest of the market's going to front run you
the other thing that he announced which was
which is catastrophic in my event was he said
we will protect the pig at 0.98 so when the peg
gets to 0.98 when the stable coin starts devaluing
to 0.98 that is when we will start deep
defending the pick and then wall street
was listening to this and they said hold on
a second you're going to defend the pack at
0.98 you've also told us you've got 3 billion
worth of bitcoin but we have 5 billion dollars
so let us like get a bit of panic going and we
have more money than you said we'll just bully you
and destroy you and go short on your on your token
and and that's exactly what happened wall street
basically we we we think we suspect allegations
i don't want to be sued for being on this podcast
that wall street uh coordinated an attack
against crypto and you know for wall street
um they don't see anything but an opportunity
they don't see people they don't see the new
economy they're not here for that they're here
so that they can attack they can do the normal
moves that they do on hitch the hedge fans do
every single day they're going to do them here
i mean we've all seen the movie billions and it
was highly entertaining and the parts that were
the most highly entertaining was when there were
sophisticated attacks that were done which were
pretty smart and you know they sold something
and they went short and it completely collapsed
and then they bought it up and it went up again
and they just did it this time so crypto protocol
and as i said earlier on my show i said on the one
hand we want wall street's money in crypto because
that's going to bring real money into crypto and
real money is going to drive up the prices but
when you invite wall street to crypto you get the
money but you also get everything else that comes
with it and everything else that comes with it
is that you're not getting these experts who have
a shitload of cash i mean under the assumption
that this was ken griffith and and king griffin
and citadel which is there sometimes an assumption
he personally is worth 26 billion dollars okay you
needed four billion dollars you needed less than a
billion dollars to collapse this whole lunar thing
for him it's like it's like come like really we're
looking down really okay let me just just just
probably had a junior trader executing it
you know that that's that's how poor it was
and so that's i mean those are those are you know
some of the valuable some of the most valuable
lessons like as a person don't get attached to a
token and i think crypto as crypto people we're
super super super guilty of that we're we're
attached to protocols almost like cults you
know you try and and and attack the xrp community
or say something not so nice about cardano or or
we're you know and what that shows is that
you're emotionally attached and you know like
you take a and i'm using cardano as a as a
um as an example but they're many like this
in crypto but you take a cardano holder and
even if the chain breaks tomorrow they'll find
a way to justify that it's not the end of the
world yes because we're emotionally attached
and so that's one you know like because we're
so emotionally attached and we can go through
why we're emotionally attached if you want in a
second because i've worked i've worked this all
out um it is so ultimately that that's the
problem you do become emotionally attached
so what do we do when you know people
love the idea of having this decentralized
so-called decentralized stable coin amazing yields
especially because all the centralized exchanges
have now slashed their rates um so do you think
we're ever going to get to a point where we have
a truly reliable decentralized stable coin or
would you say given a lot of them our experiments
bitcoin is really the only thing we can truly
rely on so bitcoin isn't is is bitcoin is
certainly right now the only thing that we can
rely on because everything else is an experiment
and to an extent we can say that bitcoin is an
experiment and the experiment has withstood the
most attacks out of any of the other experiments
and has become bigger and stronger and the bigger
something becomes obviously the less that can
break it that's just the nature of how things work
i mean if you wanted to be critical you could
say there are some attacks that bitcoin hasn't
yet withstood like an all-out government attack
okay like like a government buying i don't know
whatever i'm just giving an example like we
haven't had we've had governments ban mining
and whatever but there are a couple we haven't
and so even though i want to say that bitcoin
can never be broken let's agree that there is a
greater than zero percent chance that bitcoin can
break can be attacked we don't know about what
but it can be attacked they just agree that
there is a probability even if it's zero comma one
percent as you move down the the crypto hierarchy
the attacks become easier and easier to execute
um ethereum is much harder easier to attack than
bitcoin and you know if you if you work your way
down all the the attacks become much better so
you ask the question about whether or not
we can get a decentralized stable coin
so far we haven't proven that we can get a
decentralized algorithmic stable coin i mean
you can have a collateralized stable coin you
know uh maker does probe die and make it has
probably shown us that we can have a collateral
stable coin but then the other thing is you talk
about these insane yields now the insane
yields that you talk about are probably 20
and you're probably talking about the 20 that
was available on anchor protocol right yeah
but that was a marketing that was marketing that
was marketing that is if i were to say to you that
you could either you could either run commercials
on tv for the adoption of anchor protocol or of
ust or what you could do is you could tell people
that you have this protocol and you could take
all of your marketing budget and you could put
it into a fake high yield which was gonna be
fake for just long enough to get adoption of the
coin and then you're gonna start pulling it back
and actually recently what they did was actually
started pulling it back it used to be 20
and then it became 18 and then they were
going to reduce that i think to 16.5
and they were going to continue to do it up
until a certain point so that is the that is the
um the it was just it was just a marketing
well not gonna say scheme cause scheme is a
bad word it was marketing to get people to use
a stable coin and that's exactly what happened
yeah i think we see that across uh the board in
general um you know your loyal loyal customers
getting getting the getting the brunt of it
unfortunately um but the market in general you
know before um before all of this happened is
absolutely chaotic bitcoin um thirty thousand
dollars everything is just down even the s
p 500 everything is just crashing so what
is your opinion why are we in this somewhat bear
market which is also just not exclusive to crypto
okay so uh if you allow me i want to
share my screen and i wanted to show you
let me show you a few things so the first thing
that i want to show you is the nasdaq i want to
show you three charts and i want to give you some
perspective because you're saying that everything
is collapsing and it's you know you you're
kind of making it sound like you know we're
pretty much like this is a very very very bad
collapse and i've always been taught that when
you think something like that all you need to
do just very quickly is zoom out a little bit
okay i'm going to zoom you out to before covert
that's that's where we were before covert
okay that's that little spot over there and
then i'm going to show you where we are right
now after this terrible collapse uh two years
later we're 25 percent up which is kind of like
not a bad return if for a stock market in if it's
not a bad return for a stock market in two years
now i want to give you another i want to show
you another uh i want to show you another example
um let me just show you we're just get i'm
going to do the same thing on a bitcoin chart
and i'm going to take you to pre-covered levels
yeah there we go so so you've got uh covered wise
2020 right so here we go pre-covered levels you
were at 10 000 a coin and now you've it's three x
your return and you're telling
me that we're in a massive crash
you know like it's all about perspective so
so let's get some perspective the markets
were extremely overheated and now the markets
are coming back to some kind of rationality
as part of a normal market cycle and the
market cycle will correct itself right now
the united states is is is dealing
with unprecedented inflation and
they they created the inflation by printing
money and as i said in a tweet once i said
the fed give us and the fed take us away you
know they they gave they gave us the money and
now they're taking it away and that's pretty much
you know that's that's that's what happened so
yeah i mean i think this is a normal normal
correction i'm not panicked about it in any
in any way whatsoever i think the future for
bitcoin is bright the future for markets is
bright the fed needs the markets to relax that
inflation can calm down so that ordinary americans
can live a normal a normal life um i don't i don't
want to say another thing which most people aren't
taking into account like hell it's so cool to
make money in the markets i love making money
in the markets whether it's in the stock market
it's the crypt i love making money on the markets
but making money on the markets is not so cool
when your favorite car costs you three times what
it cost you and when your favorite uh i don't
know a restaurant cost you three times what it
would cost you inflation is a serious thing it is
a serious thing to to everybody except the top one
percent of society who who don't really care about
their living expenses and their luxuries right
if you've got a billion dollars whether your
car costs a hundred thousand dollars or 150 000
doesn't actually really matter to you like it
doesn't matter you know you don't really curse it
for everyone else the difference between
a hundred and thousand dollars or 150
000 is ludicrous it's stupid it's
ridiculous and they can't live like that
so you've got to think from the point of view
of governments regulators and even from 99.9
percent of the population the main priority
is actually to get inflation under control
even if the top one percent of us don't
make as much money on the markets for
a year or two or 12 months or six months you've
got to get inflation under control because if you
have spiraling inflation and the reason why i know
this so well is because i live in south africa
and in south africa we have periods where the
currency we had periods where the currency
halved so like one day it was seven to the
dollar and the next day was 14th the dollar
and then all of a sudden like everything doubles
in price and then your money is actually worthless
i cannot the reality is that very few people
can tap out of the system and go to bitcoin
right and maybe you're one of the few
that actually has completely tapped out
i certainly have tried to but i haven't
tapped out completely i've still got
fiat related assets i still drive a car in a
house and i still have some earnings in fiat
and those fiat earnings are getting like worse
and worse and worse so ultimately this is part
of a market cycle we shouldn't panic the
markets there's nothing systematically wrong
there's just too much money and they're
going to start taking it out the markets
and then the markets will continue to grow because
that's what markets do and that's just what it is
yeah that's a good way to put it now there's
nothing systematically wrong this is the way
market cycles work so what would your advice be
to people right now so it looks like we're in a
bear market um do you have a kind of time frame
um i know people often say the four year cycles
are finished um so is your advice right now
to start researching different projects would
it be to stack sats what's the advice i think
um always deck sets always always always deck
um but don't be irresponsible in
the way that you stack stats because
what you realized is that that you know what i
realized certainly is that everything here is an
experiment i really believe in bitcoin i've
i have more money in bitcoin than any token
than any asset than anything in my life i
have more money in bitcoin so let's just
use that as the the base starting point
right um but that's it hey it can't fail
you don't want to be all in on bitcoin especially
if you've got other responsibilities you it can
you can't fail it can fail i'm not saying it will
i hope it won't i probably won't but there is a
very small chance that it's going to fill and
when it does it's going to be like luna it's
going to go to zero on one day you know it's not
going to be a halfway if it fails for whatever the
reason of the failure is and i don't think it
will fail it's going to go to zero in one day
um how long but i don't think it's going to happen
i think we're going to be in a bull market and
crypto is going to take over the world just to be
clear how long is this bear market going to last
unfortunately because of luna i think that this
bear market is going to last longer than we think
and i'll tell you why we since i've been in
crypto and that's 2015 we've never had a tier one
level one protocol that has been with a vibrant
ecosystem with a huge wide ecosystem and
multiple projects built on it with multiple vcs
invested in both the ecosystem and the projects
with multiple lp's money collapse we've never had
that before we've never had an ethereum collapse
or an xrp collapse never happened before now it's
happened and a lot of people lost a lot of money
on luna and a lot of them lost money that they
ordinarily wouldn't have and these are crypto
believers so people who you know they always
say it's easy to get a customer to keep one of
your own customers and to get an outside customer
these are our own customers these are our people
who are now out out blown blown i had a guy
in my office yesterday who when this happened
he borrowed him his wife sold her business
she sold it for she had half a million quid
he took the money without telling
her and invested it into crypto and
well some of it was in luna a lot of
it was india and lunar orlando project
and it went to zero okay now look i know
that's probably very very very irresponsible
but it happens and we've all been irresponsible
because we're human because that's just who we are
and so what i'm saying is i think that
unfortunately this collapse of luna
is going to it was already bad we had a lot of
liquidations but now the problem is that we've
wiped out 60 billion dollars 20 billion dollars in
ust is wiped it's gone and then 60 billion dollars
in the lunar ecosystem is gone okay there has
never been a an event in crypto where 80 billion
dollars was wiped out of the market never and
now we're going to have to try and get that back
and that unfortunately as as is is is going to
prolong the winter now it could be a month it
could be three months it could be six months
whatever happens i don't think we're getting
a v-shaped recovery where we're gonna get to
all-time highs in the next six in the next six
weeks eight weeks forget about that which is
good because for one it gives you time to buy
cheap prices give you time to accumulate achieve
prices which you may never be able to get again
two there's no fomo anymore because how many times
did you buy [__] because of firmware because you
had to buy now because if not the coin was going
to run away from you and you know if the coin
never ran away from you there's no fomo anymore
no one these things aren't running anywhere yeah
they might [__] they're not running anywhere
you're not missing two x's and three x's anymore
they don't buy if you remember bitcoin today at
30 733 buy tomorrow it'll be it's 30 800 who cares
there's no more do you think it's going
lower you don't think bitcoin's going lower
so i think today was a very interesting day um
and let me show you this let me show this to you
again sorry let me just decline a call which was
shouldn't have come through let me quickly just
show you this this is an interesting thing um i'll
show you a few things which i think you'll like
um i can't be even talking to leia about
charts but i'm going to talk to you later
give it to me teach me okay so here what we
have today let me just quickly make this a bit
wider so we can all see it there we go so this
is a chart of it's called the 15-minute chart
what we're looking at here is we're looking at
the every candle represents 15 minutes so look
at what happened here today we went from 32 000
which we were on earlier 31 700 and in half an
hour when the inflation numbers came in lower than
last time but higher than expectations we wicked
down from 31.5 and we went all the way down to
29 000 which was a key 29 000 is a key technical
level with because it's the previous support
level i'm going to bore you with the details but
and then instead of capitulating we recovered
it was quite interesting we recovered
and we saw the alt coins absolutely get destroyed
in that period and everyone thought okay that's
total capitulation what we also saw in the last
couple of days is what we call a capitulation
in terms of realized profits so what is the
capitulation in terms of realized profits
sorry realize pro realized losses so
very often when people are in losses
they don't want to realize the losses you say i'm
a vegan lost a thousand a very last two thousands
but there comes a point where you get to a point
and say you know what that's it i can't do it
anymore like i can't i'm that's it's a it's the
point where you can picture it and say you're not
[__] this i can't do this anymore
and you capitulate right and this these
sparks in the orange bar are what you call uh
these what you're looking at here is the number
of of accounts or people taking realizing their
loss and you can see that every time that people
have realized their losses it's preempted a an
increase and this was we had as you can see here
a huge huge huge bunch of of of uh of
realized losses which were which were so
it's the first part of the capitulation
we could have another one tomorrow and
the next day but ultimately people are
at a point where they're giving up and
they're capitulating and that's usually the
cleanse and the beginning of a new cycle
speaking of cycles then um wait should i should
i remove the so you yeah yeah let us put us okay
speaking of cycles um okay we're not going to
see that v-shaped recovery i don't really think
anybody is expecting to given the last two years
almost and how fast everything has just exploded
um but do you think that the market is still
going to be driven by the bitcoin halving
you know these four year cycles do you think
we're gonna we're gonna have to wait until
2024 2025 then to start seeing
new bitcoin all-time highs
so the there is a there is a view there is
a theory of the lengthening cycle how the
cycles get longer after each harvey and that was
disproven a few days ago i don't know if you saw
benjamin khan who's one of the the great analysts
uh technical analyst and also a great analyst
he he talks a lot about the the four-year cycle
he said look at the lengthening cycle and that
was invalidated what you can say for sure is that
the supply of bitcoin the reduction in the supply
of bitcoin with the increase in adoption is is
definitely going to cause um a price spike however
because the spikes are becoming smaller and
smaller so like now you're mining under 6.25
and it goes to 3.125 and it goes to half of that
you're talking about less and less supply but also
you've got to make an assumption around adoption
now i'm saying that now is the pit is we are in a
in adoption now this is when we're in adoption
we're not in adoption and i don't know if the
adoption is going to increase exponentially so
i think it's going to have an effect but i don't
know if that oh just because we're now in the
next halving we're going to all of a sudden see
this this next bull market i think that that may
have been invalidated i'm very bullish on crypto
i'm very bullish on crypto adoption i think crypto
adoption is happening way quicker than we could
ever expect i think when we look at things like
a bitcoin adoption but b things like nfts like
did you ever think if i would have come to
you a year ago leia and i would sit here
a year ago not five years ago a year ago like
you know the biggest thing crypto next year is
actually not gonna be bitcoin it's gonna be
nfts the thing that's gonna have the most wallet
is gonna be nfts you would have looked at me and
you would have thought like who is this maniac and
here we are a year later and and nfts are today
like insane right that's exactly it so i think
the adoption's coming much quicker than we think
and we're going to have multiple bull markets in
crypto and i think it's going to be different
bull market from the ones that we've seen
and you're you said you're bullish
on crypto in general and one of those
one of the networks which you've been particularly
bullish on is solana last time we spoke i remember
we had a whole conversation about it so where are
you at with solano right now um given you know
the current price and the fact that the network
does seem to sort of get turned on and off again
so every every blockchain had and continues to
have its problems and as they get battle tested
they fix the problems got to remember one thing
celina's not even on a on its real mainnet it's
on a i think it's called a test alpha i don't know
what they call it but it's it's not a test net but
it's not a main nature it's an alpha mainnet or
something like that which is not even the mainnet
and that's pretty much a responsible approach
where they're going to keep fixing this
they're going to keep fixing this remember
that on a network where the fees are high
it's very hard to spam the network and bring it
to a shutdown right because if you want to try and
scan the net ethereum network with transactions
you need a lot of money in gas it's actually it's
not worth it but at the same time that makes
ethereum unusable because it's so expensive
celina the fees are minuscule so you
want to spam the salary network and
shut it down or stir it because the fees are like
minuscule doesn't it the reason negligible so
something's got to give and i think celina
will sort out its problems i think it's got
it's an amazing piece of tech with amazing
backers so like the backers with alameda research
and multi-coin capital and jump capital and all
those guys insane insane bunch of backers with
great projects working on it which actually work
and work pretty well i know if you've seen the
active addresses on solana of late but one thing
that you may have noticed is that there are more
nft trades on celina and more active addresses
than solana than any other blockchain and that's
more than ethereum there's more nft there's more
transactions not in volume but in number oh i see
that is why obviously the big transactions
banks trading at three million dollars
are all happening on ethereum ape apes or trading
and a million dollars all happening on ethereum
but where is the man on the street buying his
entities my entire office here not a single person
who works there can afford an ethereum amenity
they're all buying teddy bears and solana this
and so on and that the real shit's happening on
solana the real shit's happening on solano okay
what about polka dot you are extremely bullish
on polka dot when we last spoke what's the update
um bullish it is an experiment it's taking a
lot longer than i thought to take off but it's
really really really early days my exposure to
solana is much bigger than my exposure to pokerat
and because my conviction with celana is
much bigger than my conviction with pokemon
that said it's you gotta hedge the bit so what
are you stacking right now what is rand doing
what am i saying i have a i'm i'm very disciplined
i have a list of things that i want i have a
blueprint for what my portfolio needs
to look like and right now i'm just
filling in the gaps of what's missing in my
portfolio so what i'm stacking now is not
is not what what most people should be
stacking is just what's missing in my portfolio
like for example i said i need apecoin in my
portfolio i'm willing to i'm willing to pay
five dollars for acorn and i got it today at 5.50
so i bought it i needed stargate in my portfolio
i saw the price came down today so i bought it
and and and that's that's what i'm doing with my
portfolio that doesn't mean that everybody else
needs that what i recommend everybody must do
is they must create a blueprint for what they want
their portfolio to look like and then what they
need to do is execute according to their blueprint
and remain super focused and super disciplined
yeah that's the important thing you always need
to know you need to have an exit strategy for
me personally i don't my my bitcoin i don't have
an exit strategy it's just hold forever until i
die past it on you know put it down as cholesterol
that's it everything else i have an exit strategy
for and i think that's where people tend to go
wrong they become really greedy so can you tell us
the top like what is rand's top five holdings
right now like you said bitcoin was your was
your biggest bag it was i mean very simple it was
uh it was obviously luna which is now no longer
i mean it's now luna's pretty much non-existent
so luna was my biggest bag bitcoin was my
number two bag ethereum was my number three
bags sorry solano was my number three bag
ethereum was my number four bag four
chain is probably my number five bag
um then it goes something like near avalanche
and then it's it keeps where it keeps working
its way down so that's pretty much more
or less what my portfolio looks like
i have a little bit of corano uh and i have
a little link 2017 coins that i'm holding in
my portfolio but in terms of size salina ethereum
bitcoin um avalanche avalanche near those are the
ones that in size that would have got let's talk
about avalanche um i'd love to get your take on
it because that's sort of having the same um
kind of effect as i think it was like solana
had in terms of just like blowing up um in terms
of different projects and things that are being
built on it right now um they're trying to solve
i think they i don't know too much about it but i
think they call it the trifecta the three problems
security decentralization um and then scalability
do you think they can solve this so every
blockchain is trying to solve the same thing
everybody every blockchain wants uh security
scalability and and and uh yeah security
scalability and speed so those are the three
things that every blockchain wants to solve
avalanche is is a great piece of technology
it is a really good piece of technology
but it's just another experiment
we won't know about this experiment
until it's really battle tested now they're doing
great things emin's a smart guy he's doing some
great things they recently launched subnets on
on avalanche i think that may have been a problem
um i think that may have been a slight problem
because they allowed if you have a subnet and a
subnet for those of you don't know what it is it's
like a it's like a side chain almost which plugs
into the main chain to get the congestion away
from the main chain that's basically what it is
problem is they allow people to pay the gas
using or on the subnets using the token of
that subnet which means that there's no real
need for the avalanche token because the only
time in avalanche token is when you're interacting
with the with the main with the main chain right
and so i think that they made a mistake with those
tokenomics but i think in terms of technology it's
a very smart technology it's a multi they don't
have one chain it's actually like you've got
an a chain a beach i don't know how they call
them but there's three chains so to speak yeah
so yeah that's that's where i mean i think it's
a great piece of tech but it's an experiment it's
a risky experiment which may or may not work and
again we'll only know once it's been battle tested
but a good experience all right all right well
i hold some avax um i will always say you know
bitcoin is number one but i like to hold some
experiments it's uh it's a bear market so i'm
holding some avax and see where it goes um
regulation is coming to the us um very hard
and fast um janet yellen has reacted to the whole
situation with ust so how do you see regulation
playing out um i think gary gensler actually said
that he sees everything as a security other than
um bitcoin so biden came out and i don't even
remember but he made the executive order to
regulate crypto you obviously remember that yeah
so barton came out made the executive order to
regulate crypto in that executive order he he
said a couple of things which was super important
to note first thing he said that one in four
households were holding crypto in the us that's
a i think you said 16 million households and
that's one in four i think that that was a number
which is huge which means that you know the
reason why people are in crypto is because they
want financial freedom and because they think
they can make a lot of money it's that's why
they're encrypted yeah they're all here for the
tech but they're always here for the financial
freedom because they can make a lot of money let's
not kid ourselves so it becomes an election issue
because if you take away something from someone
which is their hope of financial freedom and their
hope of making money then that doesn't really
serve very well for you in the elections so
the u.s can't really be too aggressive on
the regulation the second thing is that gary
gansler wasn't amongst the people that was asked
to regulate crypto he just wasn't on that circuit
that memo didn't actually go to him he wasn't part
of the people that that got the memo it wasn't him
so it was everybody else it just wasn't him yeah
the third thing is that ever since we got that
um janet yellen has completely changed the
tune and in fact i heard her speaking once
she almost sounded like she was a blockchain
lecturer she knew so much all of a sudden and
so i think that the tone has changed and i think
there's becoming a massive race now from countries
to be the home for crypto which i wouldn't have
said to you i wouldn't have said that a year ago
so you have country cities you're living in miami
now um i think so you're first-hand experiencing
what the hell's going on there um uh uh uh
uh i mean you've got texas which is which
is pretty much also fighting in new york which
is claiming to to to want to bring in people
claiming you're claiming you're
just a favorite you have high taxes
do shenanigans in mining but then claim that
you want to be a crypto hub do you i mean
yeah come on that's the favorite you're still new
york city um but then you've got places like dubai
zero tax uh crypto regulation crypto regulatory
framework really fighting to bring in the smart
people lisbon or portugal but specifically
but specifically um uh uh uh lisbon is
attracting a whole lot of crypto people because
they've got zero taxes on crypto so i think that
we're not going to get a lot of very tough
regulation i think we're going to get favorable
regulation but unfortunately i do think that
regulation is going to be it's going to protect
against money laundering and rig and regulating
against money laundering means identifying where
money is being sent from place to place i don't
think that governments are going to to give up
their taxes and i don't think they're going to
give up you've got to think from a government
point of view you want to stop a terrorist attack
now if ron and leia can send money to each other
and to terrorist organizations in the hundreds
of millions of dollars with no repercussions and
no identification on the wallets whatsoever and
they can cash it out wherever they want that's
a problem like let's be realistic i mean you know
we all want bitcoin and you know we're libertarian
and whatever ultimately listen there's going to
be some kind of regulation it's going to be more
than it is now but i think it's ultimately going
to be favorable when it happens i think it's going
to bring in a lot of money and when it brings in
a lot of money i think everyone stands to gain but
then wall street's going to be in our territory
and they're going to do what they have been doing
in our territory and we're going to have to live
with it yeah it's gonna be pretty interesting so
my final my final question for you then is the
whole elon musk um saga he's soon to own twitter
um he's getting the backing that he needs um what
do you think he's gonna do do you think he's gonna
implement doge as some kind of tipping payments
mechanism do you think he's serious about doge
i think he's serious about doge um because i think
for him it's a game and he wants to show that like
the craziest thing can happen and you want to just
prove to the world that when you say something
he actually does it like you know like you know
if you're the richest man in the world then you
can buy twitter because you just decided to buy
twitter i mean just put perspective on what's
going on here right um uh uh i think he's very
serious about it now is that really good for dodge
it's not good money is it it's not but dodge
is not good technology i think the community
is great but it's not as great as it used
to be it's not as strong as it used to be
i think since the price of deutsche hasn't been
doing so well not many people are advocating dodge
and what we also saw is that when apecoin
arrived they all went to apecoin so you
know ultimately like i said i think you know
you want money you want sound store of value
it's going to be bitcoin you want money we
haven't yet discovered what the stablecoin
money is we haven't yet found a stablecoin man
yet we will find it i hoped it was going to be
luna but unfortunately for me wasn't for a lot of
other people it wasn't but it's it is what it is
all right ryan well you seem to be uh recovering
from the loss slowly um i don't want to keep you
much longer um i thought you need to mourn what
happened um so i want to thank you so much for
coming on um and sharing your experience with
us i also want to thank everyone for watching
um and also please don't forget to hit the
subscribe button so you never miss a video
um and ran thank you so much um guys please
go follow ryan if you're not already check out
crypto banter they are on every single day um
and do you have any last words for us bran no
i think uh listen guys be strong out there we've
all been through worse we'll recover we'll we'll
get through this crypto is not going anywhere and
yeah just keep doing what you're doing just keep
doing it for you leia thank you and keep doing
what you're doing you're doing amazing stuff i've
been watching how you've been growing and you know
i think it's been amazing so well done and keep
doing what you're doing i appreciate that thanks
so much for coming on guys please don't forget hit
forget to hit the subscribe button there you
go and we will see you all next week bye bye
the latest